- I do wanna point out something
that I do know about you though.
Not to go off subject,
but we have a common love.
I love Stevie Nicks,
I know you do as well.
Okay, I'm like a huge fan
and I meant to say something
about your necklace,
'cause I think it ties
in with her, doesn't it?
- She gave this to me.
Yep, there it is Kelly Clarkson.
- That is so cool.
- She doesn't give it to everyone.
- Sisters of the moon necklace.
She gave it to me,
we had an incredible experience together.
I was doing this show
called "Up All Night"
and she had known my
husband from many years ago,
so there was like this connection there.
And she came on "Up All Night",
The show that I did with Will Arnett
and Maya Rudolph many years ago.
And she and I ended up
singing together on the show,
and we actually recorded
it here at my house.
We have a recording studio here
'cause my husband's a musician,
and we recorded "Edge
of Seventeen" together
with her backup singer and all this stuff.
It was like, it was so crazy.
So anyway, she gave me this moon necklace
and I have to tell you the funny thing,
we went to go see Chrissie
Hynde at the Pantages one night,
and Chrissy comes up, you
know, Chrissy's kind of tough,
she's like, "Nice necklace."
And I was like, "Yeah."
And she pulled out from
her t-shirt, the necklace.
So there is like a
sister of the moon thing,
and I think you should be part
of the sisters of the moon.
- Oh my gosh.
I feel like I need to earn it.
- I also wanna show you
this, she gave me her boots.
- Oh my gosh, really?
(audience clapping)
- You know these boots, come on,
every picture of Stevie
Nicks in the seventies.
- I know, I love that she's
such a cool, rad person.
And I hear though that your
daughter, is she into Stevie?
Is she into that cooler music?
- Oh, she's into some good music 'mam.
My kid actually said to me,
she's like, "Mom, do you
know this song by the Pixies?
It's called 'Where Is My Mind'?"
And I was like, "Really dude?"
(Kelly laughing)
She was born in '97.
And yeah, she loves the
Pixies, she loves Nirvana,
she loves The Beatles, she loves Weezer.
- She's an alternative chick, I like it.
- You know, musical kid who
has good taste in music.
- We've actually, I don't,
I maybe shouldn't have
but I love Pixies too.
We covered "Where's My
Mind" on the show once
and I've, I just, I love.
- Oh my God.
I'd love to see your rendition.
Because wait, I have to tell
something you Kelly Clarkson.
And I have to say that because
my Steve Carell said Kelly Clarkson.
So that's you're referred
to in this house.
(Kelly laughing)
You have probably my favorite female voice
of any artist besides Stevie Nicks.
And I'm not, I am not BSing you right now.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- What?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
That's like the nicest thing
ever to say, thank you.
- I'm not trying to be nice,
I'm just stating facts.
- I know, well it's nice,
the fact is nice and I appreciate it.
And it means a lot,
'cause all those people
you just listed off are people
that I not only grew up listening to,
I still listen to 'cause
I'm a Spotify playlister.
But, I just love that like you have
such incredible music that you love.
So that means a lot like coming from you.
- Your voice is like other-worldly
and no one sounds like you.
And you can sound like anything,
and you can sing anything,
and it's pretty remarkable.
- Well, you are welcome on
my show anytime. (laughing)
Like I feel really good
about myself right now.
- Wait I follow you on Instagram.
So I watch you doing karaoke and I'm like,
damn that girl is good, damn
- Oh my gosh.
- Damn, damn damn.
- Well wait, I have to ask,
we're speaking of singing,
I mean you just kind
of like threw out there
that you casually were in the studio
recording "Edge of Seventeen"
with Stevie freaking Nicks.
Was that just the most amazing experience?
- I was freaking out because,
well she had her background singer there,
her famous background singer
that she's had for like
a 100 years, right.
And she had her teach me the harmonies,
and because I'm not that good of a singer,
I was so confused.
And then my poor husband was
like, he was recording it,
'cause he did the music
for "Up All Night" as well.
So we're there with
Stevie, and her manager,
and her background singer.
And the girl kept going like,
you know it's like this.
♪ Just like the white winged dove ♪
And I was like, I dunno what I'm doing,
and I was like staring,
and then, it was horrible.
And then Stevie gets
in there and sings it,
and it was like, yeah,
that's a legend right there.
That's a legend.
- Yeah, no, she, she's magical.
- Not a single note off,
not a single moment off.
It was like perfection, and I was like.
- Yeah and it's just
such a beautiful thing
that rasp that she has.
All right, well everybody.
- Oh wait, hold on.
Here's me in her dress.
Just know that, can you see it?
- Oh my gosh.
Yes I see it.
- That's her dress, dude.
You know that dress, come
on. (audience clapping)
- I do know that dang dress.
Oh my God, she's so cool.
Welcome back, I've been
talking with the very wonderful
Christina Applegate
everybody. (audience clapping)
All right so you've had a
pretty big end of the year.
Thanksgiving, then you had your birthday,
now it's almost Christmas.
So are you keeping busy
as usual this year?
- I cooked for Thanksgiving.
I can only cook like one or two things now
because I can't stand for very long.
I know, wee wah.
But I'll probably cook
for Christmas as I do,
'cause Sadie always likes
my weird Midwestern.
(dogs barking)
Oh my dogs are barking, someone's here.
- Oh my God, I'm so glad
you didn't hear mine.
- Sorry about that Kelly.
No, I have two dogs right here
and my dogs were literally barking
and my manager's trying
to get them to be quiet.
- Everyone's running down to
get my dogs to be quiet, sorry.
I'm gonna cook but not, I can't, you know,
with this thing I can't stand for too long
and I'll still do it,
'cause I still need to live,
you know, still gotta live that life
and be a good influence for my daughter
and be a good role model for her,
and, you know, that kind of stuff.
- And I imagine it's just like navigating
the new whatever, it's gonna
be the new norm, right.
For all those things.
- Yeah
- Well, how have you been
entertaining yourself
to get through this time,
what have you been doing?
- I watch reality TV.
- Oh, I love that.
Wait, what's your favorite?
- "Below Deck".
- "Below Deck", okay.
- Full franchises.
Every single franchise.
I have slipped into the
DMs of certain crew members
and who are now my friends.
- (laughing) I love that.
- I'm like an uber weirdo
fan, and so I watched that.
Started getting in "90 Day
Fiance" and all those franchises.
Very interesting social study. (laughing)
- (laughing) My friends
are obsessed with that one.
Well I actually heard.
- It's an interesting one.
- Heard about one of those
so I have a little surprise
for you, so can we see that.
- Christina, how you doing?
Captain Lee here from "Below Deck".
I just want to say thank
you for being such a big fan
and I want to encourage you
to stay strong and remember
that a good sailor never learned
a damned thing in calm seas.
So I know you're gonna navigate
these waters just fine.
And if you decide you wanna set sail again
you just let me know
'cause we have a deck chair
with your name written
all over it, all right?
And if you'd like to DM
me sometime and just chat,
I'm here, all right,
take care kiddo, bye bye.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Oh, I love my Lee.
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God, I have tears
in my eyes, I'm not kidding.
I literally have tears in my eyes.
I love him so much.
Kate had him send me a video
about, I don't know, six, eight months ago
and it was just very sweet.
But that's like, oh, Captain Lee,
my angel.
- (laughing) I love you.
- God of the sea, the stud of the sea.
- I am such, I was a fan
of you before I met you
but I'm such a fan of you now.
Thank you, one, for being so
open and vulnerable and honest.
That's like the most important thing
I think you can be in life
to not only help yourself
but help everybody around you.
Everybody be sure to watch
the third and final season
of Dead To Me on Netflix, it's hilarious.
You'll wanna watch it.